Microsoft is launching a new artificial
intelligence initiative this morning
that the tech giant says will help save
lives it's a 40 million dollar program
called AI for humanitarian action it
aims to speed up new AI solutions in
four areas disaster response needs of
children refugees and displaced people
and human rights microsoft says ai
technology will help anticipate predict
and better target response efforts in
these areas Microsoft president Brad
Smith is here for an interview you'll
only see on CBS this morning good
morning Brad good morning so explain how
this work how does a how it is AI
address these humanitarian challenge
well it's really a powerful tool you
take something like sudden infant death
syndrome thousands of children die every
year but we don't fully understand the
cause using more data and machine
learning we should be able to make
faster progress by working with
nonprofits take something like a famine
being able to better predict where
famines are gonna break out using
machine learning better data we can move
food to people so that we can avoid the
kinds of deaths we read about all too
often those are just two of many
examples where nonprofits have great
expertise and data science can make them
more effective so does the money go into
just you know buying more machines and
hiring more people to analyze the data
is that basically where this first
begins well fundamentally what we are
doing is teaming people in nonprofits we
have great expertise in addressing many
of the world's great challenges with new
technology to provide them with
technology and technology tools and data
science experts will provide them with
financial assistance but I think in many
ways the people the expertise the
technology itself will be more powerful
where I do have said that society that
we really need to wake up to when we
think about the benefits and the perils
a lot of people are still very afraid of
AI what concerns do you have well it is
a powerful technology we need to ensure
that as we empower computers in effect
to make decisions that have always been
made by human beings that these are
decisions that are made
ethically so you take something like
facial recognition it can help identify
criminals it might find a lost child but
it has error rates I hear it doesn't
work so well for people of color and
women that's a problem it is
rates are higher and so we and others
are working to reduce the bias we don't
want to see this technology deployed
before it's ready we don't want to see
it deployed in ways that might for
example discourage people from going to
a public space expressing their views
it's important that there be rules of
the road only if there are common rules
for those of us in the United States and
around the world are we really going to
ensure that this technology is used in a
way that I think the public is going to
feel comfortable when we talk about
artificial intelligence wired came out
with a piece that said only 12 percent
of the leading AI researchers are women
what does that lack of diversity mean
for AI development I think it's a huge
issue yeah because we need to ensure
that artificial intelligence works for
everybody and it's really a two-part
solution I think in part you need
datasets so if you're looking at photos
you have to have photos of everybody but
I think your point is also spot-on we
need the people who create artificial
intelligence for the world to reflect
the diversity of the world if they don't
they're probably going to miss some
problems that we actually need to catch
can I just pull back then for a minute
to and then talk about Microsoft your
company I recently sat down with the FBI
director Chris ray and one of the really
interesting things that he told that I
think many people don't realize I know
you know this is that China is our
biggest Counter Intelligence priority
through the hacking and there how is
Microsoft dealing with that and have you
seen that from China well I would first
say cyber security is just it's almost
job one these days for every consumer
for every business for every government
on the planet that's why we make it such
a priority it's why we're rolling out
new security features even today there
are plenty of governments that are
worried about each other these days I
don't think that this is a problem that
one can use to point at a single
government I think it's one that we need
to think about from a global perspective
we need stronger technology we need
people to implement the technology we
provide and we also need stronger
international laws in this space as well
picking up on Nora's question the
Associated Press says the Microsoft has
emerged
a kind of Internet cop by devoting
considerable resources to thwarting
Russian hackers okay you've gone after
the Russians but what about the Chinese
and are you the first line of defense
before even the government can get there
well we have taken action whenever we
seen a problem we announced action last
month and that was against a Russian
group because that's where there was a
problem that we saw
we've been vocal in the past with
respect to other countries I do think
your broader point is an important one I
did I think in the world today
technology companies as a whole are the
first line of defense the security
engineers who work at our company we
have 3,500 of them are the first
responders when things go wrong it has
fundamentally changed the role we need
to play and really elevated the
responsibilities we need to fulfill
really interesting Matt Smith so great
to have you here
keep us updated on the AI and how it
helps with humanitarian crisis minute